les véhicules méconnaissable laisse
deviner la violence de l'accident
lors de la collision cinq occupants des
voitures décède sur le coup
un sixième meurt peu après une septième
victime est hospitalisée à l'hôpital du
creusot entre la vie et la mort il aura
fallu près de quatre heures aux pompiers
secouristes dépêchés sur place pour
désincarcérer les victimes des jeunes
six garçons et une fille les victimes
sont jaunes les identités n'étant pas
encore relevé on connaît pas l'âge exact
mais probablement entre 20 et 25 ans
guère au delà on est plus habitué des
accidents sur les aires sert à des
accidents autoroutes mais impliquant un
tel nombre de victimes sur cette route
c'est absolument rarissime
le drame s'est déroulé à la sortie du
creusot sur la départementale 680
c'est le plus gros accident de la route
de saône et loire depuis 2005